the king and queen of belgium are in
democratic republic of congo diplomats
say it's a chance for reconciliation
but given the scale of atrocities
committed under belgian colonial rule
how much progress can be made this is
inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell a legacy of belgian colonialism
in central africa in the course of two
centuries millions of people are
believed to have been killed or
mutilated in what's now modern-day
democratic republic of congo
the arrival of belgium's royal couple on
their first visit to the country is
being billed as a way to move forward
but with such a long list of historical
grievances many congolese are skeptical
any real action or accountability can be
achieved
i wish that the president takes care of
what is important to the congolese
instead of making useless expenses by
inviting this royal couple we have
important things to settle here like
free education teachers are not well
paid but the president prefers to invite
the belgian king to do what to loot us
again
yes i am happy with the arrival of the
belgian king because he is going to come
and see where they have left us if the
congo has evolved or gone backwards it
is like a mother who abandoned her
children for years and she comes back to
check how the children are living so let
him come but we don't know what he is
going to bring us if it is to destroy us
even more we don't know
belgium is well aware of its history in
what was then the belgian congo
in 2002 brussels formally apologized for
its role in the assassination of patrice
lumumba the congolese leader served as
the first prime minister after
independence and was an important
politician until his assassination in
1961. belgium is expected to return the
mumbai's tooth to his family
stolen by a belgian police officer who
confessed to participating in the
assassination
the atrocities which included forced
labor torture amputations and rape began
in 1885 under king leopold ii
about 10 million congolese died
the king's brutal rule was deemed so
cruel that 23 years later he was forced
to relinquish control to belgium's
parliament but the congolese was still
unable to own land vote or travel freely
before declaring independence in 1960
democratic republic of congo had become
africa's richest colony producing about
70 of the world's industrial diamonds
most of the prophets however went to
belgium
brussels has acknowledged some of the
abuses carried out during its 75-year
rule but many argue its public apologies
have fallen short
let's bring in our guests in london
jonathan offer answer publisher of
africa briefing that's a pan-african
news magazine in brussels theodore
trevon a researcher at the royal museum
for central africa and author of the
book congo masquerade also in london
phil clark professor of international
politics at sowers university of london
a very warm welcome to you all thank you
thank you for joining us here on inside
story i'd like to begin with you phil
clark if i may returning the tooth of
the first congolese prime minister i
mean the whole thing just speaks to the
brutality
of
of belgian rule i guess um colonialism
at that time what does its return
mean what does it signify
i think the return of lumumba's tooth
really is a reminder of just how much uh
belgium and particularly the the belgium
monarchy the belgium leadership stole
from congo uh including the physical
remains of someone as politically
important as patrice lumumba it's a it's
a reminder that this wasn't just about
the
massive theft of physical goods uh the
looting of uh of congo's wealth uh it
was also that the theft of human lives
um and and of course this is also a
reminder of uh the importance of lumumba
in congolese history a sense of what was
lost this great missed opportunity in
congolese politics this revolutionary
leader who was assassinated with the
complicity of of the belgian regime so
the return of his tooth is enormously uh
politically uh relevant and and
something that has resonated down
through the decades uh i'd like to pass
over to jonathan off our answer
what's your take on on the significance
of this um and and talk to me a little
bit more if you can about your sort of
thoughts on patrice lumumba why he was
seen as such a such a threat
by by uh by the west
yes to me the return of the tomb is um
is
it's merely symbolic
okay i mean
without any substance whatsoever
to having said that i would say it's a
a good initial move at a
maybe trying to repair repair or make
some amends for the
um egregious atrocities meted out
during the reign of king leopold the
second who i mean use a congo as a
special feedback
right and then lubumba look um
in the
in the just the immediate full screener
period in africa i mean we had in coma
in ghana we had the other radical
leaders
and whom the west saw as a threat and
don't forget that the the cold war was
also running the cold war between the
west and the soviet union was running so
every each side was jostling
for influence on the continent and when
it comes to uh
congo i mean that's what congoleo as it
was known in those days um
it had massive mineral resources as we
know today okay so
the word fear was that uh look lumumba
was a radical lumumba was a city
somebody who wanted to assert kugo's
independence not just
political but accept its economic
independence and they feared maybe that
he was shipped he was shipped to the
east so what he had to do was to
eliminate a lumumba and lumumba's loss
you know it's massive it's thought it
wasn't a loss just to um congo but the
whole of africa as well
theodore trefon
there have been various statements and
apologies
to some extent by the belgians over the
years have any of them taken in the full
extent
of of the atrocities that were committed
have any of them taken full
responsibility can that be done
you know the uh there's a big difference
in between french and english about the
word that you've used which is apologies
and that's the big debate today is king
philip going to express once again his
regrets
or is he going to express an apology
because if he expresses an apology that
could result
in belgium having to make financial
restitution to congo and that that's
something that that we don't know what's
going to happen yet but the uh the
king's visit
is certainly not unanimously welcomed
either in congo or in belgium and the
the right-wing party the nva in belgium
is opposed to the king's visit to congo
now and they're certainly opposed to
making any apologies because that could
have a financial implication for the
belgian taxpayer now we have to realize
that this visit is taking place in a
very very uh
important context of uh belgian politics
and in congolese politics at the same
time no this there's a diplomatic
convergence
it's a major accomplishment for
president chelsea kennedy and as a
reminder to your audience chester kitty
was not exactly elected president he he
became president through deal making
with uh with kabila and other and other
actors
uh three years ago and the same thing
with with uh king philip now there's a
lot of
uh divergence in belgium about whether
or not
he should be traveling to congo and
what's the whole nature of this big
debate which is restitution there was uh
a mask that was
uh just unveiled in the uh the uh
history
museum in kinshasa that came from the
tavern museum and you know this thing
about restitution is very very much a
way
of clarifying belgium's colonial past
and there's a lot of emotion and a lot
of ideology and we're seeing this not
only in belgium but we're also seeing it
in congo itself
where
where philip's visit is not universally
welcomed
uh jonathan offer answer i'd like to
come back to you as we talk about um the
colonial past but what are the ongoing
impacts of colonialism on democratic
republic of congo today what what is the
legacy how is it continuing to be felt
it just contradicts look we see you know
congo you know has not
known
even a decade of peace you know since
independence in 1960
currently we see what's going on in the
eastern part of the country i mean oh i
mean you dig you dig a bit deeper you
find that it's all about
control of congo's um
vast natural resources
okay and i believe that um
the actors in congo today
are mere proxies to some external forces
who want to keep on controlling um
um congo's air resources so the impact
you know is everlasting it's until so if
uh king philip
is um is sincere
in his approach to
um
congo he must go further
i mean appeal to i mean governance
otherwise you need this and get to the
brutal problem just to make sure that
there is peace in within the whole
country i mean the israel congo i mean
it's always it's always bloody there's
always one um fight going on or all the
other so what that's what they need to
do god what happened during the colonial
times even in the in the immediate post
independence bureau is still resurrected
today the effect is still there
um
phil clark human rights watch has
suggested that financial reparations
from belgium which would essentially be
paid by the belgian taxpayer would
actually be balanced by the economic
benefits that
have been derived from colonialism on
which belgium
continues to thrive
how does belgium continue to thrive
economically from its exploitation of of
uh democratic republic of congo and and
how could belgium take full
responsibility what could that look like
you only have to walk the streets of
brussels to see the amount of wealth
that belgium derived from congo uh from
the end of the uh from the colonial
period onwards and we are talking about
the systematic transfer of enormous
wealth from one african economy to a
european economy and
this has left
the congolese state really in a very
impoverished position uh really since
the the end of the colonial period so
there's no question that belgium owes
congo an enormous
reparations package and there's a global
picture here as well we are also seeing
germany uh having to
deal with the question of reparations to
namibia for the herrero genocide the
british government has had to pay
reparations to the victims of mao mao
atrocities in kenya this is what is
spooking the belgian government at the
moment they know that there is a
zeitgeist around reparations
what belgium is trying to do to a
certain extent is do a more piecemeal
response for atrocities in the past they
they've had a commission of inquiry into
atrocities committed right across
central africa there is the repatriation
of masks and other artistic artifacts
back to countries like the drc i think
there's a hope on the part of the
belgian authorities that that will be
enough that if we have this commission
of inquiry and we send a few objects uh
back to congo that will draw a line
under history that's not the view in
congo that's not the view in the other
belgian colonies in the region like
rwanda and burundi the view there is uh
we want to see something more tangible
we want to see something much more
systematic much more material much more
financial and it needs to be on a scale
that is comparable to the wealth that
belgium stole from these countries in
the first place these kind of symbolic
these kind of cosmetic responses simply
won't cut it um jonathan or fiance i can
see you um
shaking your head there was there
something you wanted to to add
yes i agree i absolutely agree why i
represent with what is it for god said
yes i mean like i said earlier this
visit and the return of this um artifact
too whatever they're also symbolic they
need to go further and we mentioned the
word
restitution and mr clark mentioned the
the reparations in namibia from germany
as well and so forth yes
belgium's economy eventually was built
on the spoils of by under the
exportation of the congo so if
the king
has deemed the rights
expressed regrets by further short of
apologizing then they must go a step
further and see how they can offer
economic restitution
to the country because the country is
bleeding
theodore trevon
you
said that after colonialism ended
in drc it was about reconstituting the
colonial space for belgium and france
can you kind of talk me through that
well
first of all i'd like to clarify i'd
like to follow up on what my
predecessors just mentioned and that is
that we have to bear in mind that
belgium today is one of the countries in
the world with a very very high
uh
growth rate very high savings rate very
high uh human development index congo on
the other hand is usually pretty much on
the bottom at the bottom of the barrel
so there's a tremendous disparity there
the
this fact however
needs to be nuanced by
current dynamics in
congo's relations with other countries
belgium is a very very small commercial
partner of the drc today compared to
china india south africa
lots of other partners have really taken
the place of belgium in uh commercial
exchanges
congo is an important part of the
belgium belgian psyche now if if belgium
is an important country they associate
that importance with the role that they
had in this amazingly rich and uh
culturally diverse country that many
many belgians were familiar with you
know everyone so i'm american i've lived
in belgium for many years
i cannot go to any kind of event when i
don't meet someone that said oh yeah
well my uncle was in congo my father was
an administrator and you know there's a
very very deep
social connection between
uh belgium and congo and this is so the
beginning of the response to your
question about recolonizing space
because after independence
there was there was a new scramble for
territory in africa you know we're
really in the
in the context of
cold war politics
where you had
a really really severe
looming crisis between
the east and the west you know was the
cuban missile crisis you know there was
uh
mpla in angola you had
marxist leninist regime across the river
from kinshasa in congo browserville so
you know
it was a new crucible of how politics
were being redefined
and at the same time belgium
needed to keep control
primarily of the mining interests it had
in the in katanga
and this is why there was the hunger
succession there was the assassination
or the the mysterious murder of un's uh
general secretary doug hamisgold so you
know there was a lot going on and so
belgium did have a very very dubious
role
here
of course they were more agents of the
american cia when it comes to lumumba's
assassination when it came to the
catanga secession so you know belgium i
think is
very much an actor but also very much a
victim of the whole way that
uh cold war politics unfolded and
they probably didn't think that
carefully enough and this is why we're
encountering so many problems now about
uh how to deal with belgium's colonial
past which is creating a lot of emotion
and a lot of ideology in belgium today
you know we've had a number of statues
of king leopold removed from belgian
cities
there's a big debate now about renaming
streets that were named after
let's say pretty much horrible people
that were responsible for all kinds of
atrocities
so there's this debate but then
there's also quite a large segment of
the belgian population
that feels
misrepresented because
this lobby will say that well in 1960 at
independence the belgian congo
had the same standard of living as
canada and south africa in terms of
hospital beds in terms of primary
education in terms of
so this uh
the debate in belgium itself is very
very stratified and that former belgian
lobby of colonial administrators is
still quite vocal and they're probably
saluting the visitors
i just want to pick up on something that
you said um theodore and passed it over
to phil clark belgium as a victim uh
from
from cold war politics i mean i i
haven't heard that before is that
something that is
uh kind of discussed in academic circles
when exploring the post-colonial legacy
not typically no i i mean the way that
belgium tends to be talked about in in
these debates is is firstly in terms of
its colonial legacy so that precedes any
of these cold war uh dynamics that
theodore is talking about that that
that's where the exploitation uh begins
uh that that's where the pillaging of
congolese uh wealth uh begins but then
what we see is belgium continuing to
meddle in congolese politics even after
the end of colonialism and and i'd
traveled to congo regularly i was just
there 18 months ago and
the the perspective amongst many
congolese is that belgian influence
negative influence in the country
continues right up until the present uh
in terms of very opaque uh deals with
mining companies uh meddling in in
political affairs the mistreatment of
the congolese diaspora living in belgium
today so really what we're talking about
is a story of fraught uh unequal
relations between belgium and congo from
the colonial period through the cold war
all the way up until the present
um
jonathan off our answer when we talk
about reparations um and sort of
reckoning with
colonial pasts beyond drc we've been
talking or we mentioned the german
government apologizing for the genocide
in namibia
how does belgium compare to other former
colonizing powers in its attempts to
apologize to make reparations to to to
grapple with its with its quite violent
past
um i can't give any any any concrete
examples but um
i know let me use a the atrocities uh
meted out to the mao mao
you know fighters in kenya
and a year after a year or two ago um
some of their descendants and some of
the surviving uh victims and sealed the
british government you know and the high
courts here and one
so even if the british you know didn't
um directly apologize for the atrocities
methods are better to the normal at
least
um they are called their judiciary you
know
you know how to um actually
declare them guilty
okay so you do not have to um directly
maybe i apologize but
um the other means you know i probably
will be okay yeah but if you do
apologize you need to follow it up right
that it need to be you know an
open admission of guilt so you follow
that up with some sort of um uh
recompense which situation compensation
yeah that kind of thing so um that's the
way i see that it should be
theodore trevon we're nearing the end of
the program um we've got a minute or so
left but i just want to ask you is there
a shift in the way that former colonial
powers are approaching this reckoning
with their past or approaching how to
take responsibility to take
accountability
that's an important question but i would
also i would first like to like to
clarify that everything about this
debate about belgian relations with
congo
when you know
approximately 15 50
of the congolese population is 16 or 17
years old or younger so the
the vast majority of congolese are very
very far removed from these high-level
political discussions about diplomatic
restitution and apologies or regrets you
know these are people that live in the
fend for yourself economy they live from
hand to mouth on a day-to-day basis and
they're probably really not that very
concerned about what what king philip is
going to say in parliament these are
people that are struggling to feed
themselves to feed their families
and
it's true that
congo has been victimized over many many
years but this is not
this is not an excuse for a
really weakness in the whole panoply of
development initiatives
that is both
organized and orchestrated by congo's
international partners and by cleavages
within the congolese elite themselves
that are very very
uh
very very clever at keeping society very
stratified so
to place blame
strictly on one actor i think would be
really doing a disservice to the debate
it's a shared responsibility of failure
well thank you very much uh to all of
our guests jonathan our answer theodore
trefon and phil clark and thank you two
for watching you can see the program
again anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and further discussion go
to our facebook page that's facebook.com
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from meet kim vanell and
the whole team here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you